why don't we start
from the beginning what is your personal
history with mortal kombat as a video
game
how does that translate to you getting
the call for this what do you bring from
your past to this assignment talk me
through that
sure thing yeah so my the first memory i
had of mortal kombat was
uh probably in a kmart in new jersey uh
where i tricked my mom
into buying it for me for the sega
genesis because
yeah at the time it was uh it was the
first you know that that game created
the uh entertainment uh was part of the
reason the entertainment ratings board
for video games even came into existence
so yeah it was one of the first uh the
first game i think to be rated m a
i believe at the time was like uh 15 or
16 was the rating
so i was like 14 so i had to get my mom
to go and buy it so that was my that was
my my first experience and then from
there i just became a huge fan you know
i would go to
the arcade after school every day i
would uh we had an mk2 machine in my
in my bowling alley in my town little
town in south jersey
and that was just our place to go we
just hung out there for hours you know
it
was
it was like um kind of like our little
secret
society where a bunch of geeks could
just feel safe for a few hours you know
so since then over the years yeah i've
just played all the games i've continued
to follow them they've gotten so much
bigger
they've expanded so much since since
those early days but
it's a hell of a franchise and and uh
yeah i've been working for a few years
um
about five years as a writer in
hollywood and then
i was working with new line on a project
and and i knew that that project was in
development so i kind of told them i
said you know
i kind of told everybody i knew like if
it opens up please keep in mind i'm a
huge fan
i really love this i think it can really
help and so it did and thankfully i was
i got the call and
and then uh then it was a long process
then it was then it was about five years
i was on that
on the project wow yeah
i'm curious were there any kind of
little just for that group of
geeks in the bowling alley kind of
easter eggs you threw in for them
oh yeah there's so many easter eggs in
this it's insane
um i'll say one thing you know because
those were the old school machines so
that was the
you know mk2 and mk1 they were the big
they were the two big arcade games
and then three was in the irk too but
yeah we put in a lot of a lot of
references
and uh some of the fatalities in the
movie are pulled from those old
classic games so the iconic ones that
you know you remember
you know in the arcade i'll be
transferred to the big screen for the
first time
yeah what is it like to write out those
iconic fatalities what is it like to
write out
and even just like the the kind of more
basic fight scenes what is your process
for writing out
ultra violence like that yeah so the
process first of all
is uh as fun as it would be just to
throw it in there wherever you want to
throw it the
the the trick and the and uh the real
work comes into figuring out
where it makes sense for these things to
land and how they need to land so that
they have an impact on the story and the
characters because
as fun and as flashy as they are we
wanted them to actually mean something
that was part of it you know we knew we
were going to have them
but if it didn't mean anything it would
just land it with just like uh just
just kind of like oh look there's the
flashy fatality then i think you're
doing it a disservice right and so as
the writer that's that's the first thing
you try to figure out it's like all
right where
where is the fatalities going to go and
the same thing for the fight scenes
right it's
this movie is mortal kombat we know
there's gonna be a lot of fighting so
the question more is where do we stage
those fights how do we put them into the
story so that they have
impact on the characters they've impact
on the emotional journey of the
characters
and so they matter to the stakes of
what's happening uh it's very you know
so that's that's the first thing and
then from there when you actually
execute them you know it's all about
just trying to you know
write the cool stuff you can it sounds
silly but it's true it's and so
i wanted to pull from the game i didn't
want to go in making up a ton of
original stuff i wanted to be as
faithful as possible as i could to the
source material so
you know that required me to go through
all the move sets to go through you know
to watch a lot of videos of you know a
lot of the videos straight from the game
just watching them fight seeing how they
go about it and then you try to you try
to execute that as best you can
without having your fight scenes run
five six pages
try to do it in an economical way and
then knowing full well that in the
process of filmmaking a lot of people
are going to come in and they're going
to add their own input to it
and that's exactly what happened so you
know there's little it's funny i can
watch the movie and pull out and said oh
i remember writing that little
fight and then there's other stuff i
watch i'm like wow that was such an
awesome addition that was added by the
director or the stunt coordinator
or the actor in the moment you know so
so many people bring a lot to the table
that's awesome um you mentioned i think
you're on this project for five years of
development
um what were some of the kind of
previous versions of your draft or the
project that
i don't know maybe you're like hanging
on to like what could have been
that kind of thing yeah it's so you know
like it's uh
when it comes to screenwriting it's it's
a collaborative process you're working
with a lot of people
uh ultimately you're the one putting on
the page but what goes on the page is
is the is the process of a collaboration
of you know a whole group so
uh sometimes you know as a writer i i
love the lore i love the mythology a lot
so one thing i used to i
do and i tend to do is i'll tend to go
into it a little bit too
too deep right so i'll have characters
talking about
you know their backstories for a couple
pages and then you know
when when you get down to it you know
you start to realize that
uh it doesn't need that much you know uh
so uh the natural part of any filmmaking
process is editing right
and it's editing across it's not just
the picture it's the script it's
everything so you're always kind of
trying to find ways to
tell the the you know the best way you
can in the most uh
and sometimes the most concise way you
can and the simplest way especially when
it comes to something like mortal kombat
a lot of mythology
there's a lot of lore a lot of
characters um you don't want people to
get lost
and uh so so the so part of the answer
the real answer to that is that yeah i
have
probably uh scenes in my in my on my
desktop that
run three four pages of people just
talking about uh all this dense
mythology
it didn't belong in the movie uh it was
right to be pared down
yeah that makes sense um let's get into
the nuts and bolts of the movie itself a
little bit
one decision i find really interesting
is
the idea of centering it around a new
character
uh cole young and i'm curious where that
decision came from
what do you think it adds to the story
and if there are any other versions
of like was there a draft where liu kang
was our protagonist or sonia or etc
yeah so so the idea of a new protagonist
was something that
um that predated my involvement it was
something that
was uh that was a decision that was that
that was decision
uh the studio liked and when i came in i
read the draft and i said uh
i can see what we can do with this i
think you know we can strengthen it and
so
um so the reason that you know i really
liked this idea was that it allows us as
storytellers to
to bring something new to the table you
know for me it felt like
while the primary objective was to be
faithful to the mythology as much as we
possibly could
and to the lord we also wanted to make
sure that we weren't just retelling the
same
thing that had been told 100 times
before that you know this was never
going to be a remake
of the old film this was a reboot so for
that
it was what is you know how are we going
to add something new to the story
uh i you know i don't there was never
any there were never any drafts where
liu kang or sonia
or johnny cage were the main characters
and
what i'll say is i don't i've always
looked at this
as an ensemble you know i always think
that while we have a point of view in
cole young that brings us into that
world and that's part of the the reason
for his his being is that he allows
he allows the audience to kind of
venture into this very dense
mythological world
and allows us to get through a lot of
what we have to tell the audience
uh in a more organic way um you know it
was never that he was going to become
like the the poster child and and take
over the whole thing it was always that
uh it would become an ensemble and all
those kind of iconic classic characters
would kind of be unlocked along your
journey
so that by the end um you'd have they'd
all get their little moments to shine in
their screen time and then
at the end you kind of end up in this
justice league avengers style
ensemble group so um you know that was
part of it and it was trying to be
original trying to bring something new
to the table trying to
uh give the audience away into the movie
and also uh
part of that part of my job in bringing
a new character in was making sure that
if we were going to do that that he felt
like he felt part of that universe that
he was tied into this story that he was
tied into the characters in a way
that uh allowed him to live and breathe
in that world without feeling like he
was this kind of fish out of water just
thrown in from it for no reason
yeah that makes sense uh you brought up
the original 90s film
um full disclosure i am uh
i get like kind of made fun of in the
collider slack i'm a huge fan of the 90s
mortal kombat film ashamed of my friend
what's that nothing to be ashamed of
that's well i appreciate that i'll
thank you um i didn't have anything to
do why am i thanking you
um i'm curious what
were elements of that film that you were
maybe trying to purposely
borrow from and what were you purposely
trying to avoid from that film yeah no
that's a that's a good question so i
love the original two
uh people that made this movie love the
original they made the movie right so
this is the studio
in 1995 and uh and you know
we love it and and so part of our
respect for it was that we wanted to
make sure that we weren't just carbon
copying their story because that movie
exists
and yeah you know i felt like it would
be doing the brand and that film and
disservice if we just try to
stick too closely to it so one thing we
wanted to avoid was just we didn't want
to tell the same story
um plus since in the 25 years mortal
kombat has expanded its story lines to
incredible places um
you know if you go back and watch the
original scorpion and sub-zero they
don't they they're silent
antagonists they don't do anything other
than kind of have a couple fight scenes
and that's it so
those characters have grown
exponentially in mortal kombat over the
years and i've
arguably become the poster children of
the franchise now so
we wanted to lean into that for our
adaptation really give the fans the
scorpion subzero stuff that they never
got in 1995.
um i wanted to stick closely i think
everyone wanted to stick closely to the
tone too we loved
kind of that wink wink kind of
cheesiness
of the the 95 film it's part of what
made it
made it great it's part of what we
remember it's part of the nostalgia
that we remember from seeing that movie
so you know as a writer you try to you
try to pull
some of that essence out and make sure
that it still appears in the reboot uh
you know you're just going to add a
little a little crusting sometimes of
that great
95 mortal kombat cheese if you can um
but uh yeah that was that was part of it
and there's little
nods and things there's lines of
dialogue that were iconic to the 95 film
that
i felt was important to bring into this
uh like it has begun and all these you
know iconic lines that
you remember when you saw that film so
we wanted to find places for that as
well
uh just to give little shout outs and
nods to it yeah um you brought up
kind of focusing on subzero and scorpion
i really enjoyed
there was a very like profound sort of
sorrow
in this tale of revenge and i love the
way it frames the picture
um what were some of the influences in
the way you depicted their kind of
journey
especially maybe with the um the
different languages and the different
cultures kind of coming to a head
yeah that was so just to speak of that
last that last part first you know
part of the in the design of that
sequence the opening sequence is a
13-minute sequence that takes place in
17th century japan
and it was about being authentic as much
as possible and that was kind of the
kind of one of the running rules i think
where was
where where can we be authentic to the
source material and to the story and
having the actors speak their native
languages and one is chinese and one is
japanese
uh was just part of that authenticity
and you know you may look at that and
say wow that's a pretty bold move for a
hollywood film to open their you know
their
their movie with a you know a period
setting which
actors aren't speaking english but
nobody objected to it i think everybody
just wanted to tell like i said the most
authentic story possible
and for scorpion and sub-zero's arc i
knew that i knew that it was it was
important
the the trick with any of these things
is how do you tell a story that
you know that takes place back then
but that also matters to today because
we wanted we didn't want this film to
take place in the past so
we wanted to have a modern uh through
line to it so
it was it was trying to figure out okay
if i've got this very emotional
uh setup and and and i'll just speak to
that because
you know when you when you're adapting
when you're writer you're adapting
something like mortal kombat i'm trying
to find a motion anywhere i can because
you know this isn't uh you know it's not
this profoundly
deep emotional uh ip you know it's it's
so so when i looked at it and i said
where can i pull out the emotion
i looked at scorpion's backstory right
and it is tragic and it's it's probably
that
probably the most tragic thing in all in
in the whole ip so
i said i want that to be part of it i
think that needs to be part of it i
think we need to start there
and then it was a matter of okay if i'm
going to start there then it has to
matter later so how do i find a way to
bring it back
to the story so that it has an emotional
payoff at the end of the story as well
so then i decided i was going to find a
way to bookend that chapter you know
scorpion sub-zero at the beginning
and at the end but but not just have
them be isolated uh
sequences that throughout the the meat
of the movie you're tracking that story
and and then that's where cole really
became an essential part of my story is
i knew i could use him
to bridge the uh the scorpion sub-zero
storyline with the modern day storyline
and without giving you know anything
away there it's it's that that then
then i started to see okay i can see a
path i can see a way to
to uh connect these dots throughout the
journey
let's touch on another kind of iconic
pair in the film
but this one i was intrigued by how it
was a little bit deconstructed from how
we normally see them
um sonia and kano are sort of
like tenuous allies in this take on the
material
i don't know about that all right we'll
say tenuous tenuous they you know the
enemy of my enemy
uh and i'm curious where that decis they
almost gave me like
you know gritty buddy cop comedy
like kind of vibes where did the
decision to sort of put them together
come from yeah so it's a so it's a
narrative decision right so
so basically the idea is when you're
when you're constructing your
story uh you know let's say i've got
three protagonists
let's let's actually let's mix it up and
say that the movie was sonia
uh liu kang and cole so there's three
heroic characters that are going on
their journey
and they're trying to figure out what's
going on but they all have one unified
pov they all have one perspective which
is
we gotta go figure this out we gotta
beat the bad guys well when you write
that and you start to see that
it starts to feel very one-sided and so
what i always like to do as a writer is
i always try to find conflict wherever i
can because conflict drives narrative
and conflict drives character so
for me it was how do i add conflict into
the mix
of those protagonists journey and the
best way to do it is to drop somebody in
there like a wild
you know fox and a chicken pen and
that's kano and he's a guy that
uh has his own self-serving egotistical
[ __ ] desires and he's going to pursue
them no matter what
and what that does is it immediately
gives me conflict it allows him to
be a problem and a pain in the ass for
our heroes as they go on their journey
and it's just it's always more of a it's
always more of a
rewarding uh setup to have for your
characters is to have conflict like that
so
that was the idea of putting kano in the
mix and then
uh and then josh uh added so much to it
he's you know he's he's he's a great
actor and brought a lot to
their you know so says jess and as well
and so
that that kind of sonia kano you know
right on the edge of killing each other
there's literally scenes where they
almost do
uh just became a you know a great way
for me to put conflict in the movie
we see the poster with johnny cage he
says i'm heading to hollywood
did that come from you was he was cage
always the character we were going to
tease what does that mean for the future
of this franchise
so uh so no so uh
so so basically the idea is like movie
one we were always kind of setting this
up as
well i was setting it up i don't know
it's basically in my head
i always saw it as pre-tournament right
pre-tournament
then hopefully tournament the post
tournament so the idea was like this was
going to be a pre-tournament
movie that was that would hopefully sow
the seeds for
the tournament the fight from from the
beginning you kind of conceived this is
a trilogy for chapter one
yeah interesting a writer you you and
this is by the way this was this was um
the the overall everybody was focused on
movie one you don't get a trilogy
without it so
uh but as a writer you should always you
should never be paying yourself in a
corner that's my mom you should always
be thinking about where can your story
go even beyond the two hours that i
that you know this is not a lot of time
so the two hours i have to tell this
story where else can it go
so i was kind of i saw it as kind of
leading up to uh something bigger
and um and so the idea then became all
right we're gonna have you know we have
certain amount of characters we can fit
um
you know don't have the luxury of having
uh individual
movies of all these characters uh i'm
gonna get thrown right into avengers
mode which is uh
fun and a challenge um but you know i
knew that there were other characters i
just i couldn't get in and and that
actually didn't even make sense to bring
in yet for the story so
yeah then it became a matter of uh well
who's the big characters that we want to
save you know because you also don't
want to
you know you don't want to use
everything you know uh and so
yeah johnny johnny's tease at the end
the button
it changed different ways i remember
there were different versions of it
um you know that poster was something
that the design team
did uh which i love i love i picked them
i picked citizen cage because i just
loved
i thought that was fight for your rights
so i picked i picked that
and put in the script and then they
designed that amazing poster
and then it had lived in other places so
it actually wasn't the button
for a while earlier in the story like
they were walking and you just see it in
the background
and we felt like uh that just wasn't
enough i think it just felt like it
wasn't enough so you wanted to you
wanted to really hit on it
and i remember there was a version for
the end
uh where they would they actually went
to like the lot
so cole and the other sonia and went to
like the studio lot
and they i forget what it even was they
like pulled up and they were and it was
like they were going
right it was going to be shot at warner
brothers right and they were going to
the meeting and
but it just felt like with the pandemic
and everything it just got to it it was
hard to do a lot of that so
i think um i love the way that it kind
of buttons and it's simple and yeah
hopefully
we can tell more of those stories
absolutely was there ever a moment
did it get far enough into
pre-production or production where
johnny cage was cast actually no no no
gotcha never cast no that's that's i
guess that's probably why you see him
from the waist down
good point good point filmmaking trick
yeah
i think i've only got a little more time
with you uh so
let's move a little bit away from mortal
kombat um
i'm curious about uh
a saints row movie yeah that you're
attached to and i'm especially curious
because
for me what's fun about that game or
what can be fun about that game is the
open world aspect of it the kind of
chaotic i can do anything
anything goes kind of thing what is your
goal what is your tactic to kind of
funneling that into one kind of cogent
story yeah it's
so it's a tricky one right i mean i love
the franchise i've played all the games
huge fan of it
and we have a director f gary gray who's
attached to it he's an amazing
visionary director um has done some
incredible one of my some some of my
favorite films including set it off
which i still think is one of the best
oh i love said it off it's fantastic so
good
he's got a great vision for it he knows
what he wants to do i think from a story
why from a storytelling perspective it
was
you know it was two things it was it was
the the tricky things with something
like stanford is gonna be tone
right away right because you know if you
know the franchise you know that it
it's it basically had two tones it has
more of the gritty tone which is the
first couple movies and then it goes
kind of bonkers and just absolutely
insane
and so we wanted to make sure that we
weren't isolating either of those so
that so it's about it's about just
trying to find uh find the tonal balance
where you have real characters
real stakes part of it with mortal
kombat 2 it's like you wanted to you
wanted to feel real you want the
characters to feel
real as much as possible but you also
want to lean into
what made it fun and lean into that
craziness so
part of it was trying to figure out that
tone which i think it's finally gotten
into a place where
it makes sense and then it was a matter
of what kind of movie is this because
how do you take an open world movie and
tell a story so
you know i looked at different films
that i really love i'm a big fan of 70s
cinema so i looked at the warriors
uh i looked at uh escape from new york
uh
speaking the language yeah just some of
those classics and i said well how do we
how do we kind of pull from some of
those and tell our own unique story so
i'm excited for it we'll see
that's awesome so am i uh last question
for you
what is the space invaders film looking
like
ah i really this one's really really a
passion project of mine you know when i
i uh one thing that you know when i got
it
it's funny like i first felt a couple
years ago three or three actually maybe
like three four years ago
and it came to me and i was like you
know and i passed on it because i just i
couldn't figure out i did what i didn't
want to do is i didn't want to do
independence day i didn't want to do a
big alien invasion movie that i've seen
a hundred times i always try to try to
avoid that kind of stuff so
i couldn't figure it out and then it
came back around like a couple years ago
and um and i was like you know what i
gotta i gotta figure this out because i
love the original game it's the
grandfather of
video games really it was it's the still
i think one of the biggest all-time
selling games ever right in vivian
history so
um so i had to figure it out and so i
found a really unique way into it that's
all focused on character and just
emotion and
heart it sounds crazy when i'm talking
about space invaders but
i pulled a lot from my own life growing
up in new jersey and it's just this kind
of
it's just it's it's a very uh emotional
uh personal story so i hope
i hope it happens that's awesome man
thanks so much for your time congrats on
mortal kombat
thank you greg thank you my friend thank
you for taking the time